are you happy I couldn't be happier
do you ever get the feeling that when
things are going really well something
Awful's gonna happen hello Elora Bishop
I can help you I'm your daughter
how did you find me and organization and
helped me find you guide oh you're not
gonna believe me I was 17 my parents
thought adoption was the best adoption
I'd like you to meet everybody I'd like
that
guys this is hey I'm staying after
school tomorrow so one of you needs to
pick me up together I can pick you up I
know he's your biological daughter but
we don't really know her we didn't raise
her see tomorrow little [ __ ] we don't
know anything about our values her
decision-making so tough now are you so
we just get to know her better
what are your parents think about you
meeting us they're supportive they had a
biological daughter my sister they
wanted to have more kids so they decided
to adopt your parents seemed really
great I guess I always wanted a sister I
thought you said you had sister a few
weeks ago your daughter Bree showed up
at her house who's this
what's going on here
mom she's her sister it wasn't for you
giving the daughter away I would have
had I turned for myself
you
you